democrats have impeached donald trump
because of his actions on january 6th
that is the reasoning that we have been
told up until now
donald trump incited an insurrection on
january 6. now the trouble
with this line of argument of course is
that you can go back to the tape
and see what trump said and he said be
peaceful
don't be violent before during and after
the riot at the capitol
so that doesn't work well joaquin castro
not julian castro not the former future
president joaquin castro the congressman
has the updated reasoning
as to why they are impeaching trump
this attack did not come from one speech
and it didn't happen by accident the
evidence shows clearly
that this mob was provoked over many
months by donald j
trump and if you look at the evidence
his purposeful conduct you'll see that
the attack was foreseeable
and preventable not just about one's
speech it was foreseeable
it was predictable it was so vague
it was in the innumbra penumbras and the
emanations and
in between the lines and when trump said
be peaceful he was really saying be
violent that probably does not stand up
to
legal scrutiny and unfortunately well
joaquin castro was trying to bail out
the democrats failing case for
impeachment
i think he just undercut it entirely on
michael moses the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the michael knowles show
my favorite comment from yesterday is
from henry knox
who says this is actually pretty
profound when victimhood
is currency there will be lots of
counterfeiters
that is very true that is
extraordinarily true
that's something you can absolutely take
to the bank
probably means you can't rest easy right
now everything's so in turmoil
but if you do want to try to rest easy i
would recommend you do so on my pillow
you know my pillow i've talked about how
wonderful my pillow is
i'm sure you know mike lindell who's the
founder of my pillow i got to tell you
for years i saw mike lindell i liked
what he was doing
so i would have supported my pillow even
if the product wasn't any good
i'm not exaggerating in any way my
pillow is the greatest pillow i have
ever slept
on they sent us a freebie just one
pillow
we were talking about them coming on the
show and
my wife and i were fighting over it so
much now we love them is the only pillow
that i am going to use
they don't go flat they're made right
here in the usa
best of all it's the quality even forget
about the politics for a second
the quality is so good you can get a
queen size premium my pillow regularly
69.98
get it right now for 29.98 that's a 40
savings
kings are only five dollars more
head on right now they will extend their
60 day money back guarantee
to march 1st 2021 go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners square
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts
on all my pillow products including the
giza dream bed sheets
the my pillow mattress topper and my
pillow towel sets or call
800 651 1148 and use promo code
dailywire i'm in washington dc right now
as you can tell if you're watching this
instead of listening
i'm in a hotel room not too far away
from the white house
also not too far away from the capitol
we are covering the fake impeachment
trial
which is falling apart minute by minute
i'm not going to cover really the
play-by-play of all these arguments
they're very foolish arguments very glib
arguments they have been from the
beginning it was always pretty weak
and i think as you heard joaquin castro
there uh
it's it's falling apart minute by minute
so i don't think there's any reason to
pay attention to it it's also as we
discussed yesterday
not a constitutional impeachment trial
but it is worth looking at it
for what it says about our broader
politics you know there is someone
called josh hawley the republican
senator
he was like doodling on his paper during
the during the trial today
or yesterday he was uh he was reading
material that was completely unrelated
to the trial
because this is not worth paying
attention to broadly speaking
we live in a very glib time we're we're
now treating
impeachment which is a very very serious
constitutional process
like it's nothing like it's just you
know something that you do
and ordinarily i was in dc at this very
hotel
a year ago for the first impeachment
trial of donald trump now we got another
one
we're probably gonna have another one in
a year or two years after that we're
living in a very glib time not just on
this issue of the impeachment
but on this issue of the entire biden
agenda gensake our favorite white house
press secretary
of the biden administration was just
asked a question
about joe biden's transgender executive
order
this basically within the first week of
biden being in office
he abolishes women's bathrooms and
women's sports at least at the federal
level obviously they're going to fight
it more at the local level
so she's asked serious question hey
if if you're going to let men you know
play in women's sports and menus the
ladies room
don't you think that's sort of unfair to
women here's her answer
what message would the white house have
for trans girls and cis girls
who may end up competing against each
other
in sparking some lawsuits and some
concern
among parents so this administration
have guidance for schools on dealing
with disputes rising over
trans girls competing against them with
cis girls i'm not sure what your
question is
the president's executive order i'm
familiar with the order but what was
your question about the question is does
the president have a message for
local school officials on dealing with
these kind of disputes that are already
starting to arise
between uh you know trans
girls who are competing and cis girls
and a level playing field
particularly in high school sports when
it leads to college scholarships is
there any kind of messaging
or clarification that the white house
wants to give on the executive order
i would just say that the president's
belief is that trans rights are human
rights and that's why he signed that
executive order
and in terms of the determinations by
universities and colleges i would
certainly defer to that
joe biden believes trans rights are
human rights
our white house press secretary is
mustering all the sophistication
of a twitter troll or a sort of
an everyday feminism headline
trans rights or human rights that
doesn't answer my question what about
the girls
who are now going to lose out on
scholarships and lose out on awards and
lose out on
admission to various colleges and
various athletic programs because men
are competing against them and men are
bigger and faster and stronger so
they're going to beat them
what what about little girls who now
have to change in front of men at the
public pool give me an answer on that
don't don't just give me some ridiculous
slogan trans rights or human rights did
you hear that term that jen saki used
she said sis cis for those of you not in
the woke
no cis is the opposite of trans
so if you're a cis woman or a
cisgendered woman
that means you're a woman who knows that
you're a woman
you're not a woman who thinks that
you're a man or a man right
so this brings up an issue that i've
seen some
conservatives do i myself have done it a
couple times but i don't want to do it
anymore
i don't think you should qualify woman
or man some conservatives do this now
they'll say
well you know caitlyn jenner is a
biological man
caitlyn jenner is a man not a biological
man
spiritual man whatever when you say
things like
biological man or whatever you qualify
man or woman in any way to better accord
with gender ideology
you are granting the premise of gender
ideology you're granting the premise
that your biology can be one thing and
your spirit can be another thing
as though your true identity has nothing
to do with your spirit
it's kind of the flip side of the gender
argument the gender ideologue
argument is that you know i look like a
man but i feel like i'm a woman
so because you know forget about my
physical body
deep down i feel like a woman therefore
i am truly a woman my body has nothing
to do with who i really am
well the the kind of biological man
qualifier is just the opposite side of
that it's saying well you know the way
your body is that's exactly what you are
you're purely material you're not a soul
and
the the real answer is you're a soul and
a body and it's one and it's
united together and a man is a man and a
woman is a woman
and there's no reason to qualify these
things at all i don't think
we should in any way validate this
gnostic delusion of gender ideology
but they're doing it they're doing it
everywhere in great britain right now
i kid you not a group of hospitals is
instructing midwives and maternity
departments to use different terms
when treating transgender patients to be
more gender inclusive
meaning instead of breastfeeding you you
have to use the term
chest feeding instead of
breast milk you have to use the term
human milk
okay instead of
breast milk you could also say milk from
the feeding mother or parent that's
another long one
very inhuman this kind of language
erases women right it says no there's no
such thing as women we're all just kind
of generic people
and so anything that might distinguish
women from men we're going to
get rid of it but it's inhuman more
broadly
we shouldn't use this kind of thing we
shouldn't indulge it in any way
and conservatives to be polite want to
do that you want to say well look i
don't care
if a man thinks he's a woman and he he
wants to wear a dress in his own private
life who
for be it for me who am i to say you are
somebody
you can have an opinion on this men
should not dress like women and behave
like women
if they do it it should only be as part
of some very sort of outrageous costume
or something
it should be with the acknowledgement
that this is strange
out of the ordinary and not the way
things are supposed to be
conservatives need to get much more
serious about this sort of thing
we live in such a glib time that you
have the radical saying well there's no
rules to anything we can liberate
ourselves however we want
men can be women women can be men
there's chest milk and what
whatever you know milk from the feeding
parent
and but then on the other side of the
glibness you've got these conservatives
who are refusing to offer any other
vision they're saying yeah whatever you
want to do
long as i don't have to pay for it as
long as it doesn't affect my bottom line
do whatever you want
no guys that is not a serious political
vision
when you when you offer a political
vision you have to be able to say this
is the way the world is
and some things are true and some things
are false and i'm going to stand up for
the things that are true
and i'm going to oppose the things that
are false but the identity politics
is not primarily at the level of sex the
identity politics today
is primarily at the level of race
it's an ugly fact but the racial
identitarians
overwhelmingly of the left are dictating
that
you even hear it from guys who are sort
of fake republicans like joe scarborough
joe scarborough who is uh you know his
job is to basically
be the court jester in the kingdom of
liberalism he's supposed to say i was a
republican congressman and
all the republicans today are bad and
you know then the liberals applaud him
and they give him some money so joe
scarborough
went on tv on his show that very few
people watch but a lot of journalists
watch
and he said the the problem with our
politics right now
is that some people in america cannot
accept
the fact that they are not going to be
in the majority now what does that mean
people can't be in the majority are we
talking about religion
are we talking about race are we talking
about
sex i don't know i guess just as a
raw numbers women make up most of the
population
they're the only only aggrieved minority
that happens to be a majority in the
world
what scarborough is talking about here
is race and it's
ironic because he's a white guy and he's
he's talking about how
white grievance is driving the trump
phenomenon it's the same sort of thing
you hear from all democrats the only
reason that republicans do what they do
is because they're racist and they hate
people who aren't white
and they're neo-nazis and they're white
supremacists and uh we've
got to get rid of them but his argument
reveals
uh what is what is so rotten and
frustrating to people
about the the rise of identitarian
politics at a time when we're told we're
all supposed to be equal
it is remarkable that that so much of
this is
all about an america that is changing
and certain people who cannot accept the
change
and they don't understand uh that that
they're not
going to to be the majority
uh in this country anymore um
and it's fascinating i i have you know
been reading
um along with kate uh going back and
reading
uh flannery o'connor short stories
and one after another after another
after another is written about white
people uh in the 50s and
early 60s uh adjusting
to changes and not being able to
understand what is happening
around them in the south there's so much
here
to digest it's such a glib statement
one because you're ascribing racial
animus to one
group of people i i think baselessly uh
in a way that you would never ascribe it
to black people you never say ah black
people they're just all upset because
they're black
they're all hispanic people they're all
just up sick as because they're brown
but joe scarborough say nice white
people they're just upset because
they're white racists
but moreover
there was a pew research survey on
racial consciousness in america the
question was
how important is your race to your
identity is it important or is it very
important or is it not really important
at all
white people in america have the lowest
racial consciousness and it's not even
close
for basically every other racial group
these people consider race to be either
important or very important to their
identity
greater than 50 for white people
it's about 15 percent now i think
most people i know would say oh that's a
good thing i don't consider
my race to be the number one
uh aspect of my identity it's probably
like number 100 or something right say
hey michael what are you i'm catholic
i'm american i'm a conservative
i'm a new yorker originally i'm
italian-american i guess that's sort of
a race it's
kind of more like your your family
background especially in america where
people come from a lot of different
backgrounds but sure but it's pretty low
down right
and then at what point would i say i'm a
white guy i don't know pretty pretty low
down the list
so i think what joe scarborough is
saying here is wrong
just as a matter of social science you
know
the surveys don't really back that up
but let's say it's let's say it's true
that uh white people are are upset
because they're not going to be the
majority anymore and that's just the way
it is
people like joe scarborough people on
the left
are ginning up racial consciousness for
every racial group
right they're saying it is good to be
racially conscious black people need to
be more racially conscious
that's why there's all these anti-racism
quote unquote
uh re-education trainings
that's why we have black lives matter
right we all all these kind of woke
racial groups
so everyone needs more racial
consciousness except for white people
at the same time we're told white is not
a race
it's a social construct there's no such
thing as white people
but then the left says that whiteness is
evil it's terrible it's the worst thing
in the world white people need to
have certain disadvantage white people
need to
apologize and feel very sorry about
themselves we need to
decolonize all manner of society and
take the white people out of it and
right on and on and on so they're saying
there's no such thing as white people
but also white people are the worst
people in the world and then they're
saying if there is any white racial
consciousness which
by the way i don't really think there is
but they're saying if there is that's
the worst thing in the world
what is supposed to happen here what is
joe scarborough
proposing he's saying
white people should have no no sort of
group thought and also man white people
are the worst and we're just gonna
get rid of them and they're not gonna
have any political power
what is supposed to happen there now
what i think would be nice is if
race were not the primary uh
mode of thinking in american politics
but i think
the left knows that it is greatly to
their advantage
to increase racial consciousness for
their likely voter groups so you see
this all over the place elon university
is hosting a white caucus you might
think that the kkk
is being revived that's not the case the
white caucus
is for white students to quote unpack
race and systemic oppression
this is what the email from elon
university reads a white caucus is a
space for white identifying individuals
what's a white identifying individual i
guess that could be like me right i'm
sort of swarthy
i've got this sicilian skin i guess i
could pass
for uh not a white guy but i do i
identify as a white guy i guess
for white identifying individuals to
engage in conversations that unpack race
and systemic oppression
in this world wherever you're told that
white people are like the worst thing
ever and whiteness is a synonym for evil
who would choose to identify as a white
person i don't know
this is why by the way the the uh sort
of
public acceptability or even
encouragement of castigating whiteness
as a category this is why you get the
rachel dolezals of the world
this is why it seems every month or so
you find another person who's you know
a gender theory professor or a critical
studies professor
who's been pretending to be hispanic or
black for their whole lives it turns out
they're just white people
because they're trying to identify as
another race because they've been told
that
being white is a very bad thing the
email goes on
white caucuses allow white identifying
allies to have these conversations in a
way
that does not burden or re-traumatize
people of color re-traumatize
white caucuses give white people a space
to learn about
and process their awareness of and
complicity in
unjust systems without harming their
friends of color
a lot of woke white liberals
believe this sort of thing it's very sad
it just is as sad if you were to grow up
actually i guess from the same ideology
if you were to grow up and be told
because i'm black
i cannot succeed i can't get ahead the
system is just
out to get me people who push this idea
are like tony heasy coates
who is a very wealthy very famous very
admired writer why he's admired i have
no idea but he's
admired by all the very fancy people he
wins half a million dollar macarthur
genius grants
and his message is basically the whole
system is rigged against black people
and they can't do anything
it's a horrible message to tell somebody
and it's
manifestly a lie right tonic easy coats
his life is evidence that that's a lie
in the same way how awful is it to tell
some white kid yeah man you're evil
you're awful
because of the color of your skin not
it's not we're not saying you're
oppressed
we're saying you're the oppressor you're
just a vile vicious evil person
and there's no way you can ever fix it
because you are
white you know you participate in this
thing called whiteness which has become
a synonym for evil that's a horrible
thing to tell kids
i don't know i guess i guess i'm immune
to
to what liberals might call white guilt
you know i don't feel
guilt because of my skin color i don't
feel uh
pride you know racial pride i don't
don't really take
glory or shame in the color of my skin
but increasingly
this is what we're told to do it's not
just at elon university purdue
university
was just proposing a mandatory class
in anti-racist thought what is
anti-racist thought
it's racist thought i know isn't that
ironic the purdue musical organizations
announced in january its members would
be required to complete six classes
on anti-racist thought this includes
white privilege
white supremacy white fragility
and white saviorism and how to be a
better ally this according to emails
that were
seen by the washington free beacon they
have backed off of this
since the emails came out these uh these
courses would have been taught by
well-known con artists ibram kindy
and robyn d'angelo they were supposed to
start this month they've now been
postponed
this is purdue produced a pretty
conservative university
purdue is run by mitch daniels former
republican governor of indiana
conservative guy very intelligent
is a keen understanding of education
even he
is being forced to adopt in some ways
this vicious
vile bigoted sort of stuff
it's sort of trite at this point even
say it it's glib to say so i don't even
want to but to say
imagine if there were a course called
black privilege or black supremacy or
black fragility oh my god could you
imagine
but that's not the way it works because
as
actually as our as our friend told us
henry knox at the top of the show my
favorite comment yesterday when
victimhood is currency there's going to
be a lot of counterfeiters
when victimhood becomes the currency of
a society then victimhood is actually
going to become a privilege and people
are going to claim victimhood is best
they can and then the piesta resistance
nicole hannah jones probably one of the
biggest race hustlers in america one of
the most prominent racial identitarians
in the country
she created the 1619 project to quote
reframe american history to say it's
evil and bigoted and racist
this woman just doxed a conservative
journalist you do not want people
showing up to your house that you don't
want showing up to your house
and one way to protect against that is
with ring so much is going on at our
front doors these days you're getting a
lot of
visitors especially me because i've got
my newborn baby and a lot of people want
to see him
sometimes it's the guy delivering the
crib sometimes it's the guy
delivering my pizza sometimes it's my
mother-in-law and i
will open the door or keep the door
closed maybe depending on who the person
is i'm not going to say it's one of the
other
either way you can find out who is at
your door you can see and speak to them
with ring a really really great way
to know who is outside to secure your
home
i like if i'm out of town sweet little
elisa can know who is outside the door
before she opens the door right now you
can get
a special offer on the ring welcome kit
at ring.com
knowles that comes with rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro
which is the perfect way to start
building a ring of security around
your home also makes a great
housewarming gift
i've given this away to a lot of my
friends because it's cool it's futurist
it keeps them safe
doesn't cost that much money so you get
credit for giving a good gift and you
don't need to spend a lot of money go to
ring.comring.com
knowles also a daily wire membership is
the only way you should be watching this
show i know you can get the show on
apple podcast google play spotify
stitcher all over the place
only though with a daily wire membership
can you get all the extra features
head on over yeah i mean you've heard it
all before all the different shows
behind the scenes content new shows
coming
wonderful leftist years tumblers the
best way to consume leftist tears head
on over you will get 10 off right now
with promo code knowles go to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
nicole hannah jones of the new york
times probably their most famous
journalist at this point
of 1619 fame just doxxed the washington
free beacon reporter aaron
siberium aaron cebarium
reached out to her because the times has
this very strong policy now no use of
the n-word doesn't matter if it's
to give context doesn't matter if a
reporter is quoting somebody
they had a reporter who was discussing
this word in a sort of academic fashion
two years ago in a private conversation
they fired him for it they said we will
not tolerate this word in any form
but then they find out that nicole
hannah jones is that her name or is it
hannah nicole jones i always forget you
know it's anna nicole smith
and nicole hannah jones nicole hannah
jones
used this word jokingly on a podcast
recently and of course she's not going
to lose her job
because the new york times is not going
to to enforce this across the board as
they say they will
they're not going to enforce this
regardless of context
they're going to let people who can
claim racial or even say it and people
who cannot will be fired
no matter the use of it so they're
obviously going to
let nicole hannah jones off the hook
and they're not going to let this other
guy off the hook they're just going to
do it based on how they perceive
someone's grievance to be that will
permit them to say various other words
uh it's an ugly system i don't like it i
think it's very silly and i don't think
we should indulge that sort of thing
but but think about how nicole hannah
jones
is playing this game she's not playing
it according to logic she's not even
pretending
that there is a logic to what she's
saying nicole
hannah jones wants to reframe american
history
she hates the country and she wants to
say that the country is not good
the country is bad and here's why she
lied to do it
the central thesis of the 1619 project
is that the american revolution was
about preserving slavery
it wasn't academic historians even on
the left said that was complete bs
finally after a long long time they
issued a slight correction but they
didn't erase
the project now this woman when she's
asked any
question about her behavior doxes some
kid
you know when you get doxxed as a public
figure that can
that can threaten your life that can
threaten your family's life
doesn't matter she sent out this kid's
email address
and this kid's cell phone number to half
a million followers
she eventually deleted it but she kept
joking about it
she doesn't care
i've said before on this show there are
times in politics
when you can try to work together you
can try to do a little kumbaya you can
try to have a little unity in healing
no matter what joe biden is saying right
now about unity and healing that's not
what the left is interested in
and the right cannot force it i know
there are some squishes on the right who
they're in the professional loser caucus
you know guys like mitt romney
all they want to do is be loved by the
left fair enough
sometimes there's a reason to try to
reconcile a little bit meet in the
middle
but your opponent gets a say
in politics your opponent gets to say in
war your enemy gets to say
and the left does not want to reconcile
they want to dox us they want to impeach
us
after we leave office they want to call
us nazis and
evil rotten people they want to attack
us on the basis of our race or
certainly on the basis of our politics
on the basis of our religion
they think we're deplorable irredeemable
i'm just using hillary clinton's words
there
that is that is a virus in the country
that's
that's a real dangerous virus in the
country some viruses are a little less
dangerous than that
that one's real dangerous and i'm not
the only one who thinks so emmanuel
macron leader in france
is describing woke american politics
call it political correctness call it
radical leftism
he's describing it in the way you would
describe a virus
he's saying that that it is being
imported now into france it's not native
to france
it's coming from america and it already
screwed up american society and now
screwing up french society
he said i assume that's how he
begins every sentence i don't i don't
speak french very well he says we have
left the intellectual debate to others
to those outside of the
french republic by ideologizing it
sometimes yielding it to other academic
traditions meaning
american and anglo ones when i see
certain social science theories entirely
imported from the united states with
their problems
which i respect and which exist but
which are just added to ours
i say to myself that it is reasonable to
make this choice so we must very clearly
reinvest on a massive scale in the field
of social sciences history understanding
of civilizations
by creating posts stepping up dialogue
on and on and on we need to basically
defend
the french intellectual life against
woke american leftism
because he knows that this stuff is
poison for a society it's absolute
poison
i remember in the in the early political
correctness debates
in the 90s a big topic of my book that's
coming out soon speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which you can pre-order right now by the
way
a big topic of that is these political
correctness debates
even much earlier on and early on then
the french said you know we don't have a
problem with this france has their own
problems they're like burning cars in
the streets every day you know
blood running down down the uh chauncey
they say
but we don't have this problem of
political correctness
that's an american problem and now we're
seeing the flourishing of that sort of
problem here in the united states and i
guess we're exporting it around the
world too
we can't make peace with that right we
can't
they don't they don't want peace when we
when we try to reconcile with that what
are we getting we're getting more and
more political violence right it's just
not possible
to uh to have a peaceful society if
you're
coming to terms with that you have to
fight it you have to stop
this kind of woke ideology and its
tracks that's the only way
that you're gonna you're gonna have
peace you have to be firm on these kind
of academic and political movements
speaking of france by the way uh this is
my favorite headline of the entire week
france is not living up
to the paris climate accord why is this
so ironic
i don't know if you're familiar with
geography paris
a very prominent city in france this is
a french project
the paris climate accord france not
living up to it
we already knew many countries weren't
living up to it actually
after the paris climate accord was
signed and then trump came in and pulled
us out of it
actually the united states leaded the
way leaded the way led the way
uh in in meeting the goals outlined in
the paris climate corps that we weren't
even a member of
now joe biden signed us back up but it's
all just fake it's all just glib
it's all this shallow nonsense no one
takes it seriously not even france takes
it seriously
it's just a facade to
permit the liberal establishment to
continue on its path
of national and i suppose international
destruction
you can't take these things at face
value the impeachment trial is not an
impeachment trial
the environmental protocol is not an
environmental protocol
the same goes for climate change climate
change broadly right it's
it's this sort of larger than life topic
that is just a way to push through the
same policies that the left has wanted
for a hundred years
it's all so shallow
is there any way to fight back i think
there is i don't know about the
paris climate thing i don't think it's
going to matter all that much but there
is a way to fight back
when i think of the shallow politicians
in this country one guy who comes to
mind is
governor patrick bateman you know
governor american psycho out there over
in california
gavin newsom says one thing does another
locks down
the the state says you can't go to
restaurants next they catch him at a
michelin rated restaurant
sitting next to his buddies nobody's got
any masks on they're eating
thousand dollar meals he doesn't believe
in any of it well
newsome might have to face some
consequences for that
there has been building for a while now
a recall effort for gavin newsom
if if they get enough signatures
newsome's critics will be able to
force a new election hopefully kick him
out of office
they're pretty close they needed one and
a half million signatures
it's very hard to get one and a half
million signatures here for anything in
california
they need to get it by march 17th
the petition to recall newsome currently
has
1.4 million signatures they're only 100
000 signatures off that's the good news
they've still got a month more than a
month to do this so
it's very possible it's accelerated in
recent weeks
now the downside is it's not really just
one and a half million
because what's going to happen then is
the political operatives working for for
newsome
are going to go into the petition and
start taking off signatures if maybe
i don't know let's say the address
doesn't match the name of the signatory
they're going to cross that out
if the person's not a resident of the
state of california they're going to
cross that out
if maybe if someone's moved i know i
know some people who have left
california recently so they're going to
take
off a lot of signatures every political
campaign does this
republicans and democrats both do this
which means that this petition to recall
newsome
is really going to need more like 1.8
1.9 maybe even 2 million
if it actually wants to take hold
can they get that i they do have a month
very hard to get half a million
signatures in a month but that's what
they have to aim for
because otherwise i think what you're
going to see is they'll get one and a
half million or they get 1.6 or
something and then
ah whoopsy daisy the system beat them
again because they took off
and disqualified enough signatures this
is a concerted effort here
to to push the agenda of the liberal
establishment they've got big tech
they've got the
administrative state they've got now a
lot of elective offices
they've got universities right they've
got hollywood they've got the media
they've got so much
they've got sports that it's very easy
we've got to be really on our game here
very serious otherwise we're going to
get rolled which which does seem to be
happening a lot
this liberal establishment does not
have the best interests of the united
states at heart
i know that sounds hyperbolic i don't
mean it just to throw bombs i'm saying
it as a purely descriptive matter
so much of the national debate over the
past
five years i guess is between globalism
and
nationalism and whenever we use these
isms you know they're a little imprecise
but what do we mean by globalism by
globalism we mean people
who do not feel particularly strong
bonds
to their nation to their country they
feel that they are citizens of the world
you know people in new york who feel
they have much more in common with
people in london and paris
than they do with people in peoria or
omaha or something
so they want a much more globalized
world globalized markets
and a lot of conservatives used to be
all for the globalized markets the
trouble with the globalized markets is
inevitably globalized regulation will
follow globalized political institutions
will follow
you lose a little bit of national
sovereignty
that's what we're seeing the liberal
establishment going in for what you
could broadly call
globalism and the right going in for
what you could broadly call
nationalism i don't really consider
myself a nationalist
i'm not saying the nation-state is the
be-all and end-all of political
order however in this debate do we have
some affection for our country or do we
give it all away to the u.n or something
yeah give me america i'm i'm with
america
but some people are not and i'm not just
uh castigating them
in a hyperbolic way mark cuban has
decided
that the mavericks his sports ball team
is no longer going to play the national
anthem before the games
the mavericks have not played the anthem
before any of the team's 13 home games
this is the first instance i think of
any pro sports team in the u.s
taking the anthem out of a game why is
he doing that
because he doesn't like america very
much obviously
and there's a business angle to it as
well there's a report out now that
sources close to mark cuban say that he
chose not to play the anthem before the
games anymore
not because he doesn't love the us he
totally loves the us
but because many people feel that the
anthem
doesn't represent them and they want to
continue discussion of how to represent
people from all communities when
honoring the us
at a game you've heard also in recent
months the idea of a black
national anthem or if there'd be a black
national anthem there has to be a black
nation
black nationalism how how much have we
heard in the past years of
the scourge of white nationalism rising
well here we have the mainstreaming
of other kinds of racial nationalism
it's being encouraged for certain groups
and obviously discouraged for other
groups
it's not that the left has a problem
with racial identitarianism or
nationalism broadly speaking
they just have a problem with it for
certain people and they like it
for other people now
there's so much wrong with this i mean
obviously
the flag has to represent everybody
the reason that some people feel it does
not represent them is because the left
has been attacking american national
identity
and stoking other forms of identity in a
very very shallow and cynical way
the nba is coming out and saying no the
mavericks are not allowed to do this
sorry you'll have to keep playing the
national anthem sorry mark cuban
part of the reason mark human's doing
this obviously is this identitarian woke
politics
there's a there's an economic reason
though too which is that the dude is
owned by china
the nba is owned by china so much of
american media
to say nothing of manufacturing and
other interests is
owned by china china's a really big
market pays these guys a lot of money
and they value the almighty dollar more
than they value bonds of loyalty to
their country
to me i hope conservatives are paying
attention to this because to me
this is maybe the clearest example of
how the free market quote unquote
is not sufficient to craft a political
vision
the that's the free market mark cuban
hates this country and he wants to sell
out to china
it's a free market it's his economic
freedom right he can do whatever he
wants no
no free markets are great they're a
wonderful instrument to human and
national
flourishing but there has to be another
end there has to be something deeper
there
has to be bonds of loyalty to your
family to your community and to your
nation that has given you so much
speaking of giving back to your nation
president trump or at least people
around president trump have suggested
that he might run again in 2024. i guess
trump at the white house christmas
parties
suggested this too he's gone on camera
they might run
for president but he's kicked off
twitter how's he going to run
the cfo of twitter was asked if trump
runs again
if he wins again will he be allowed back
on twitter
absolutely not former president trump
was banned if he came back ran for
office again and and was elected
president would you allow him back on
the platform
so the way our policies work when you're
removed from the platform
you're removed from the platform whether
you're a
commentator you're a cfo or you
are a former or current public official
and so
remember our policies are designed to
make sure that people are not
inciting violence and if anybody does
that we have to remove them from the
service and our policies
don't allow people to come back
president trump could be good enough for
the american people good enough for the
electoral college not good enough for
twitter
we were talking about how if your entire
political ideology is the free market
which by the way is not possible because
the
civil authority people through politics
need to set
what the free market is it's not totally
open it's this is a finite world
everything has limits on it so it has a
certain shape
to make an idol out of the free market
is sort of a nonsense in itself
but if you do that then there's nothing
wrong with what twitter is doing
yeah you can kick off the dually elected
president they already did
they already kicked trump off while he
was the sitting
duly elected president and it is
astounding to me
that there are not many but there are
still some conservatives
people who call themselves conservatives
who say well that's great
build your own twitter we won't let you
of course you can build your own twitter
but we'll shut it down kick it out of
the app store
kick it off of amazon web services kick
you out of your banks
kick you out of society yeah build your
own internet
yeah build your own economy build your
own
government that's that's what we try to
do in politics
we try to go in get political power
have the people give us political power
of the ballot box and then we have to
wield
that political power and there is no
free marketeer no libertarian economist
who can convince me
that it is at all acceptable for some
big tech oligarch to censor
the duly elected president of the united
states be it
in 2020 or be it possibly in 2025
or 2026. very glib
time when even conservatives would
consider defending this sort of stuff in
the name of some
abstract free market that that does not
exist in reality
but not all is bad i don't want to you
know we're living in this glib time i'm
in washington right now so it's kind of
rubbing off on me i'm just very
frustrated
by this place it's kind of it's kind of
like baghdad here right now
there's just national guard everywhere
streets are locked down
it's it's uh uh not right it doesn't
feel
the capital it's like fort knox right
now
white house you can't get near so i
don't like that but there are
there are some glimmers of hope in the
country
one bit was actually during the super
bowl there was an ad during the super
bowl these are usually extremely woke
that was maybe the most pro-life tv
commercial i've ever seen
you have this swimmer and she
is missing part of her legs
very well shot mrs long yes
we found a baby girl for your adoption
but there are some things you need to
know
she's in siberia and she was born with a
rare condition
her legs will need to be amputated
i know this is difficult to hear for her
life
it won't be easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mrs long it might not be easy but
it'll be amazing
i can't wait to meet her
we believe there is hope and strength in
all of us
toyota proud partner of team usa it's a
beautiful advertisement it's really
great this
girl you know was going to be adopted
born in siberia she's got this condition
they say well yeah we're still going to
take her we don't care that she has a
disability
and she becomes this paralympic athlete
that's wonderful now
they couldn't have made it about you
know a woman who's contemplating
abortion and
maybe you know the kid in in utero is
diagnosed with some condition
well is he's gonna have a tough
condition oh well i'm gonna have the
baby anyway i'm not gonna get you they
couldn't get away with that
but it's exactly the same issue am i
gonna keep the kid or am i going to
give the kid away either to siberia or
to death
and the ad was saying no choose life
that's good even even though there is
suffering in the world
uh it's okay it's better to live
this world involves suffering i was
reminded of this on my flight to dc
because basically the only time that i
ever wear the mask these days is when
i'm on an airplane because you they
won't let you on the airplane
if you don't wear the mask if you refuse
to wear the mask while you're on the
airplane they will arrest you i mean
it's not
then they'll put you on the no fly list
and you just can't travel anymore so
it's the only time
where i've made a prudential judgment i
think it's better to put the mask on and
go
talk about how fauci is a jerk and no
one should listen to him you know go
talk about him on various shows and
things like that
then to not not travel at all that's
very uh
sort of crestfallen at this sad state of
affairs for the country
uh the way we're all locked down like
lemmings wearing these stupid
muzzles on our faces these filthy pieces
of cloth
flying in to cover this fake impeachment
trial which is dominating the national
attention
all sorts of glib nonsense vile
racial politics creeping up all over the
place
republicans without a spine and i was
joking though i had
boethius in my bag this writer who wrote
the the consolation of philosophy
he wrote it while he was in prison about
to be executed by uh
the gothic emperor theodoric and
he wrote the consolation of philosophy
about how you know look fortunes go up
fortunes fall and there's a lot of
suffering in this world
and compared to what boethius was facing
probably we've got it pretty
pretty good and but
by pursuing truth you can
rise above that you can realize yeah
this is a broken fallen world
boethius a lot of people don't know was
a christian he's actually venerated as a
saint in the catholic church
you can rise above that sort of thing
and it just doesn't uh
you shouldn't let that get you down i
think we're in that kind of place right
now in our country
things just look terrible they just look
really bleak and there are very few
glimmers of hope
but hope springs eternal in the human
breast and i'll probably be more hopeful
when i get out of washington dc see you
tomorrow i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show gina carano gets fired
from disney plus
basically for being a conservative
because that's the way things work now
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen